excellent so this was the hit or miss
why hit or miss because the ball that i
throw is either below
or above the function now
what we will actually use is the sample
mean the sample mean is different
i would like to integrate this function
and i can take samples of it
samples here mean that i have f of x and
2x
i can substitute a number and i can
evaluate the function there so i don't
know the integral of the functions too
complicated
but i can evaluate it i can evaluate it
at 0
at 0.15 at 2 and values like that
how do i compute the actual integral
from this function from this
these samples well we will
take a look through an extremely
difficult example
which is integrating x okay so let's
let's solve this with
multiple different methods method one
what does the mathematician do find a
primitive function what is the primitive
function of x
x squared over two all we have to do is
substitute one
at zero and therefore we get one half
excellent so i know that i'm looking for
one half
what does the engineer do the engineer
knows that this is a linear function
therefore this is going to be the area
of the triangle
what are the lengths of the triangle the
base
is one because i'm integrating from zero
to one the height is also one
because if i go one to the right then
i'm going to go
one upwards as well because this is x
so the area of the
triangle is the base times the height
over two
so this is one half again now
we have the mathematician and the
engineer what does monte carlo guy do
a monte carlo guy didn't study
mathematics at all so he cannot do
any of these so what monte carlo guy is
going to do is
he's going to take samples of this
function so i evaluate
f of x at 0.2 how much is it at 0.2
well obviously 4.2 simplest possible
example
what about 0.4 well at 0.4 this is 0.4
and so on so i have taken four
randomly chosen samples from this
function
and this is called sample mean this
means
averaging so let's take the average of
all of these so the average of all of
these values is
exactly one half so this gives me
the actual perfect result
for an integral that i could otherwise
not solve
now we can code this very easily
in just a few lines of code and there's
already excess lines of code because of
printing
and whatnot but you can you can see how
small this is
this is the actual function this double
f
that i'm interested in and f of x equals
x
so it's not really that difficult what
is the output of this program
after many samples i approach very close
to
one half up to quite a few digits
so this works really really well
but there's something really interesting
about this so if i draw
one sample from this integral then i
have
an overestimation of the result why
because i'm looking for 0.5 and i have
0.87
what about 10 samples is this an
overestimation or underestimation
10 samples
i wasn't paying attention to the
sentence before because i was thinking
about 1 million
samples to get damn it okay so the
question is is 0.61 more than 1.5
to a good approximation is this 1.6 more
than what
exactly so this is an overestimation
excellent what about 100 samples
lisa will help me out hopefully
it's louder
perfect that's an underestimation okay
what about
1 000 samples who will you help me out
maybe
may i ask her no estimation it's an
underestimation yeah ask your name
okay marco knows that this is an
underestimation
and this is a weird behavior right
because i have
overestimations and underestimations of
this integral
but in the end it seems that they are
going to the deviations are going to be
less and less
so this almost looks like a sign so it's
like
if you like algebra the convergence is
something like
uh sine of x times x
is it no because it's going to get large
sine of x
over x so this is like a sine
that starts out with large deviations
and large amplitude and it gets smaller
and smaller
this is how the convergence of monte
carlo estimators
go and this we call by the way
stochastic convergence so it means that
it can be over and
under the integral but as you add more
samples it's guaranteed to be closer
let's have another example let's
integrate this function
2 times sine square of x
and what you could say that yes this can
happen one
but this has very low probability
because why would you hit the same
region over and over again
and you can also do smart things like
like putting a grid
on the function and sampling that so
that's that's one thing
but what you will see later that we will
have
unbiased estimators and this means that
you can expect the error
to shrink in time but
this will be a couple of lectures down
the line
is is everything fine regarding this
that was a good remark that's exactly
how it goes okay
what does the mathematician guy do look
for primitive functions
excellent what is the primitive function
for the sine square of x
well it's one half of x minus the sine
times the cosine
let's do the actual substitution we have
our
well-earned pie again what does the
engineer do
well these are not triangles anymore so
you better look it up on
go from alpha and you will get something
like this and the result is again
pi so wonderful engineering works
okay what does monte carlo guy do monte
carlo guy doesn't know war from alpha
doesn't know
mathematics doesn't know anything but
this he has his
20 whatever line c plus plus program
let's take samples of this what are we
looking for what was the number
what was the end result it was pi
okay so let's substitute this function
where this double f is now the sine
square of x
and i have also this multiplier of 2 in
line 35
so this on the right side you see that
this is what i am looking for
this is what we have changed
now just one more time what am i looking
for
what would be the perfect result okay
excellent they run this program and it
starts out
maybe pretty well 3.6
mm okay and as i add more samples i will
get one
not pi i get one
okay so i have been lying to you
i have been lying to you all along this
doesn't work at all
and we don't have the slightest idea why
this doesn't work
that's one of the most important lessons
during this course not not because of
this thing who cares
we'll study this thing and sort it out
but
you start out if you have a difficult
problem you start out trying to
understand it
with your intuition you don't start
throwing
multi-dimensional integrals everywhere
you start out thinking of
what is going on there is a diffuse
interaction
there is scattering in the atmosphere
how does it look like you use your
intuition
and your intuition can get you very far
so in the integration of this f of x the
intuition of this sample mean could give
us the perfect solution
but there may be more complicated cases
where your intuition fails
and this doesn't mean that intuition is
not useful
but it means that it can only take you
so far so if you
if you have barriers like this that you
cannot go through intuition
then is the point when you start using
mathematics
and you start to evaluate
what is going on you start to look at
the details so
use the intuition to get an idea of
what's going on
and then if you run into obstacles use
mathematics to sort out the details
that's one of the most important lessons
out there for you
when you will go out there and try to
study
really complicated theories
so this doesn't work i have been lying
to you all along
how can we sort it out well
after the commercials we will know a bit
more the commercial
will come in the form of thomas
because he is going to travel to japan
for a half a year
long half year long research project so
he has a few
lectures left three of them
in particular and he has to hold them
now because he's going to
take the plane afterwards so the next
three lectures
are going to be held by those and
i mean the timing is a bit sub-optimal
because i had to cut this lecture in
half
but at least you know how monte carlo
integration works and he is going to
tell you more about this
and then we will complete this unit and
at the end of this unit
so before i get too complicated
three lectures from from us then i come
back
we complete this lecture we will know
how to write a global illumination
program
so this is exactly what we're going to
do i have implemented
the whole global illumination thing it
is beautiful it can do everything it can
be
do beautiful indirect illumination
caustics
i think it's in 250 lines it's readable
it's understandable
and many many people have learned how to
do global illumination
from this program so after three
lectures from thomas then i
finished this that's one lecture the
next lecture is going to be a cold
walkthrough so we are going to take into
we are going to look through the code
what i have written how this works
how is frana's law inserted here where
do i use smells log
i do all these things you will see
everything in code itself it's going to
be very practical